a new year is upon us and we're starting
it out with this January horror
film So It
[Music]
Begins so night swims a horror film
starring Wyatt Russell and car Condon
they buy a new house with them and their
two kids caveat that they find out later
the pool is haunted by an entity scary
creepy Shenanigans ensue funny enough
after the first pool kill and the movie
started going and it was you know boring
I was thinking all right that first pool
kill scene would have been a fine short
film I would find out a little later
turns out it was this is based off of a
short film from 2014 which taking a
short film and drawing it out to feature
length we've seen that work before night
swim on the other
hand positives first let's let's be
sweet before we're sour uh there was an
underwater shot or two near the end in
particular that I thought was
interesting sounds like I'm really
scraping and trying to find compliments
for this movie but there was a shot one
in particular near the end where I was
like well that's the most interesting
thing that's happened in this movie
almost feels like one of those scenarios
where you know we've all done it you're
talking with your friends oh that'd be
really cool in a movie this happens just
spitballing for horror movie moments and
shots and they came up with this one
moment this one shot for a movie a
horror movie that takes place underwater
then the true tragedy and weight of the
fact that you have to build an engaging
movie around that shot that's one of the
problems this movie runs into it has to
put people in these dangerous situations
but make it feel natural it never feels
natural there's a scene where this
girl's playing Marco Polo with her
boyfriend at night so you know
something's happening she has her eyes
closed she's saying Marco he's saying
Polo and then the creepy things start
happening she starts actually getting
freaked out but they have to keep her in
this scary situation which means she
can't open her eyes so she just kind of
doesn't she's like stop it stop messing
around you're freaking me out I was just
like then open your [__] eyes open
your eyes and get out of the pool this
ends right now or you can keep them
closed cuz we got to pad that runtime
this movie largely feels like runtime
padding that's one of the dangers when
you have an interesting premise that
works for a short film that you want to
stretch out to feature length film you
got to make it work and feel organic
this feels like a short film premise
that works as a short film and about an
hour and 15 minutes of other [__] I
appreciate that this movie is only 90
minutes that said it's still felt like
two full hours they did it right in
making it only 90 minutes and it all
feels for not that Marco Polo scene just
one of the many scenarios characters
just make dumbass decisions and that all
boils down to the writing the script
it's bad I will say there were a couple
of actors in the movie that I felt made
the most of it there's their characters
in the movie there's a pool technician
guy and a real estate agent I really
feel like the actors who played those
two characters were like are you [__]
serious with this script okay here
here's what's going to happen I'm going
to deliver these lines in a way that
showcases some of my comedic timing I'm
getting something out of this good on
them they brought some levity to a film
that was largely a boore that said it
felt like they were in a completely
different movie I named them because
they stood out more all the actors in
the movie you can tell are trying
there's only so much an actor can do
with the script sometimes it's just
blatantly obvious that it's not on the
actors I mean [__] Wyatt Russell and
Carrie Condon we've seen them be great
so there is that data yeah in large part
this movie felt like a Franken Stitch of
a few other horror movies but it's in a
pool this time funny enough I do see
potential in the lore I say potential
because the reality of the situation in
this movie is that it's shoddy as [__]
but the potential is there for a
possible sequel you get some better
writers on the script for a sequel could
be that Annabelle situation where the
first movie was asked but the sequel is
actually pretty enjoyable though the
lore is inconsistent as [__] like why'
the thing kill the cat I mean the cat
dies in The tra trailer so it's a
spoiler but not a spoiler but it's
something you should probably know
especially if you're a cat person but in
terms of what this entity is what it
wants and why I left the theater like
wait a minute why' it kill the cat
there's no actual reason for it to do
that other than the fact that this
movie's borrowing from a lot of other
horror movies and well in other horror
movies the family pet dies so I guess
we'll steal that one too even though it
doesn't make sense if it just had better
momentum it might have been able to be
that fun cheesy bad movie that you can
laugh at with friends at a Halloween
party as it stands this is the movie you
put on during the Halloween horror movie
binge when you're ready to call it you
want the party to wind down well we're
starting 2024 off right so to speak
watch the short on YouTube save yourself
about an hour and 25 minutes all right
so night swim have you seen it what did
you think about it if you're going to
say it or what's a surprisingly
enjoyable January horror film for you
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see
more
[Music]